we are
alive
hi I have had one hell of a crazy
week puffer's going well what's been
busy I am a bit too fried to work on the
bigger projects that I've got going on
at the moment so instead of staring at
my screen getting nothing done today I
figured I'd jump on stream and we do
something kind of
fun been wanting to do this for a while
it's like one of things where it's
just getting it done uh probably I
should be doing this later rather than
sooner but you know I've got a nice
little block of time to do this here got
a spare five
hours so
yeah um if you haven't seen
whoops let's show what Robo kid is first
and uh what we're going to do with it
it's a pretty cool project it's actually
one of the things that taught me how to
program back uh
in
2012 maybe it's more than 10 years ago
I'd done a little bit of stuff by then
already sophomore High School what was I
14 something like that
16 no it must have been later I don't
know anyway anyways so they've got these
robots Okay yeah so you can see here
it's like a tank battle thing
right um and this was originally a
project that was created to teach people
how to
code but that's not what we're going to
be using it for today though actually to
be fair kind of for free at the same
time we're going to get a version of
this thing that's just way better than
the original uh for that exact purpose
but the thing is this was originally
implemented in Java and Java is
Java um and it's really slow so what
we're going to do is we're going to
implement this very very simply
in C with python bindings and we're
going to use this as a reinforcement
learning environment and I guess we can
make scripted agents as well for it
we'll see where this goes I don't think
that this will actually be all that hard
to
do um
yeah I started on it a little bit just
for like an hour the other day so I have
a little bit of an idea of where we're
starting from
and uh folks are more than welcome to
jump in and help with this live if they
want let me pull the code up what is
wrong with
Docker uh
uh let me figure out what's wrong with
my docker
I have
space let
me let me just reboot Docker
here because I don't know what it's
dude like where's my
stuff
[ __ ] well on the mean
time some of this stuff in here what's
wrong with Docker yeah I know right to
be fair Docker is actually usually very
very stable I probably just need to
clean up my uh my dis uh if this
restarts my whole machine I'll be back
in a second I don't think it
should
so where is
this this is what this looks like right
you have just have very
uh it's event based which is kind of
awkward for
us yeah the fact that it's event based
is a little awkward so we're going to
probably have to do
stuff a little
different maybe
not this is such a terrible way of
programming it's kind of funny
I think we'll be able to get it to do
basically the same thing
though um I have a little thing written
already where you can like move a thing
around on the screen we're going to need
to get the tank Graphics we're going to
need to get like radar and stuff
working and firing and energy and all
the stuff in here but I I don't think it
should actually be all that much work
so we can kind of just replace this with
like a like in the step function or
whatever it's like
if robot scanned fire right it's the
same thing so we can literally have
yeah we can have a very similar API to
this it's just instead of this we'll use
flags or
something um because we're not doing
this event
nonsense and the API will be C with
python
bindings come
on come on docker
H it works it's funny how since I
updated it they've completely redesigned
the whole UI of it I don't know that's
kind of
weird see Docker not that
bad and
environments pull
this buffer lib environments ocean Robo
code we've got a h
here and we have our
C test file
to
Ln link RB so we can
linux4 Das
s build this
equals okay so I wrote this in an hour
yesterday um I had meetings like all day
so it's kind of
jun you can turn stuff goes way too fast
I think the frame rate's just really
high or whatever
yeah there you go it's got tank controls
which are really
awkward
right you have to like steer with W with
a
andd I mean I you can probably already
get like reasonable movement out of RL
with this CU like it doesn't have it has
way better reflexes right
let's see yeah like already if I just
like I'm careful with it
eights so what I have in here so far
I've got this little robot struct it's
got data for its position its velocity
it's heading also has a gun and radar
heading few other things
get allocated
here uh we have a few quick things to
clean up so I made a degree version of
this function I don't think there's one
of those
oops in see robocode is awesome I did my
first Q learner oh that's
cool that's very cool I figured that
like some people would recognize it
right so what we're going to do is we're
going to make a c version that runs
literally literally millions of steps
per second um and you can run like RL on
it with puffer just out of the box so
you know imagine running PO for a 100
Years of Robo code on your
GPU that'd be pretty cool
right it's actually very easy to do as
well unless I'm dramatically missing
something I don't think it's that
complicated of a simulator to build
let's figure out the uh some of the
drawing stuff first here so when I left
this yesterday uh I was trying to figure
out how to get it to
draw a
and take your current radar heading
minus
20 plus
points okay so what does it
say so it says X left
is
here and then X
right is the
same and then y left is up here and Y
right is
733 oh I know what's wrong yeah yeah
yeah I know what's wrong um you have to
draw it in order yeah this is an
obnoxious Graphics thing uh you have to
draw the points on the triangle I think
it's from I forget if it's count
clockwise or
counterclockwise so let me think we have
left
work huh yeah literally that's all it
was so here's our initial very crappy
radar cone thing
we'll fix
that this doesn't let you
do oh no this will let you do
transparency
right because I can just do like color
RG and then 128 and that's transparent
right yeah perfect so here's our
radar and in fact I can even I can make
this way
better because we'll draw the radar on
the
bottom oops I uh what did I what am I
missing probably need to put the robot
at the top right
right okay the RO the radar doesn't
rotate yet we need to fix that it's also
way too
short I don't know how uh what the cone
is supposed to
be but let's just do
fine
right okay so here's your radar cone
let's actually go figure out real quick
how it's working in the
radar radar scans up to 1200 units
away
okay so I should be able to just do
right I don't know if the math is right
on
that I don't remember a cone radar I
remember a single
array um is that the
case this is a cone in here it's a
smaller cone so I have to figure out
what the width of the cone is but it's a
smaller
cone let me
see hid's radar arcs
so it's 45 degrees
by
default but it with the physics it can
go up a
bit
um so this is 22.5 I
guess it doesn't look like that though
if you look this is way narrower isn't
it oh
it's I
see so you're kind of right you're kind
of wrong
it's it's like a beam if you're standing
still but when you rotate each tick
yeah okay so we'll have to implement
that that's
fine that's cool
though and you have a radar turn command
and a gun turn Command
right let's go look at the API
well this is just
bloated where's the thing that we
actually
need which is like on hit and
stuff oh wait it's I forget it's Java
right so it's Advanced robot
is there's actually a lot
here but a lot of it is kind of
colors yeah a lot of this is just
redundant and like bloated cuz Java
okay so there not actually that
[Music]
many
head we need to understand the uh the
game physics I
okay so they have this wonky coordinate
system I don't know why they came up
with their own coordinate system or that
puts 90 Dees
here robocode determines acceleration
for
important it's open source isn't
it two different types of robots
different
stuff uh which types do you mean do you
mean the basic in the advanced ones or
cotlin like this is the most Java thing
to ever Java
physics I would like to match their
physics if I can find it in here but
geez Advanced is also different
stuff is
it okay I don't remember that
fair and even if I find the code I don't
know if I'm going to understand what the
hell they're doing
here well we'll just go like this I
we'll literally just copy the
uh API here a little bit
do you even have access to this ahead
function
oh maybe there docks
here does not return until it's
this it's actually
unclear is there a way to get to the
source code for
trying to figure out how to implement
their
here uh
basic
thing there's like 20 times more code in
here than there should be
moved basic robot I'm trying to figure
out how they're doing their acceleration
and it's just
okay well I don't know so um we're going
to just come up with something I
guess
because I don't know how else we will do
that we would do
let me think you can you have an
acceleration
right
it's kind of a weird way to do the
controls though to be honest
yeah I'm going to get stuck on this
because I really I can't think of like a
reasonable way of doing
this well I'm going to use the uh I'm
GNA just freaking chat jity see if I
like I doubt it actually has
the robo code stuff substantially enough
but
yeah okay this is this makes sense yeah
I was sort of thinking of this um it's
probably just guessing as well but this
is
probably this is probably how it's done
to be honest
uh we should be solving for acceleration
right so 2D over V
and then what we do
is acceleration is greater than
one it's equal to
one this is from the actual game itself
we know that this is correct is less
than -2 it's equal to -2
and then what we do is robot
velocity add the acceleration so this is
probably a decent little function here
we'll see if this is correct or anything
to uh change the action space a little
bit right
so this will be
float star
what do what can you do here you can
move
um I don't know if we want to actually
do continuous
though I think we do instar maybe
and then we'll simply
do action
offset
three y times n actions and then we'll
just do in
uh this can be
move
or yeah I guess this
is move
action then this is going
spe gun action and radar
action
cool yeah I know what we can do so now
we do just float uh radar heading is
going to be your radar heading here
this happens at the very end as well
right yeah this happens at the very
end uh this move stuff so we'll we'll
have to change the order of these but
essentially
there also needs to be a turn action
doesn't
there now we have to do
clipping I believe
right
um we can probably just assume for now
that we're going to always be given
valid action data
right yeah we'll just assume that for
now
so I think there's something weird that
happens with the game physics that we
have to get right
here this is added
to okay so these things get added onto
each other which is kind of
wonky so the way that this works is gun
action plus
equal turn
action and then radar
action is going to plus
equal or is going to be incremented by
gun action like
weird uh which we can Implement like
this actually plus gun action even
easier
okay start so this is going to be radar
start
oops start robot. radar heading
and actually we need to figure out which
is going to be on the left side here
don't
we yeah we need to figure out which is
going to be on the left side
though I think we can cheat it if we
just know if the turn is positive or
negative right
we
go yeah so if the turn is
negative then this is to the left
zero radar left is going to
be this is
cool so now we have radar left radar
right
oops this is radar left this is radar
left this is radar
right radar
right no longer need this
that should be
handled
um there is
the robot turn and then the gun
handle neither of these are hard these
are both very easy
okay we don't need to handle move and
render this is going to be for
the the gun oh
also I'm being very stupid here because
most of this stuff should just go into
step
right yeah that most of this stuff
should just go into step anyways
yeah let me just
start moving all
this cuz really this should all be in
robot you have your
actions then for the
gun it is uh simply going to
be
robot
gun equal to gun
action
if
360 same thing with
radar um but we actually do need to do
radar start and end
now
start little radar
let's just do prev like
this it'll be
cleaner okay so we set the
previous radar heading
plus equal radar
action we can clip like
this
uh this stuff actually does need to go
back
into yeah this stuff actually does get
kept here so radar
I think we can do
float left
equals uh and I don't really like having
it be based on the
action but we'll do it this way for now
so we'll just
simple if it's l less than
zero robot
heading heading
and now this stuff is is easy
right this is just
draw
line e
be uh let's let's make it a little
nicer
two
pause we'll reuse this anyways
right gun pause
yeah this was definitely a good idea to
do this today I can tell there's no way
I'd be able to do uh stuff on the bigger
project this is Chill
though line robot pause gun pause
four and white
we have radar left radar white uh
right and
then X left X
right we'll do Vector
go now we can draw a
triangle robot
B then this is going to
be color like
this cool now we have the gun drawn we
got the radar
drawn uh we want to draw the gun on top
of of the
radar that can go
here and then actually the robot gets
drawn last
move
[Music]
action uh right I forgot to update the
actual game
this yeah no this is now
this is going to be
right and then this is going to be turn
turn
action which we don't really need to do
we don't need to have a turn action
function
really um
robot yeah there's your turn action
right
there and then what the heck is this
thing oh no there does need to
be a turn action it looks like
okay there does need to be a turn action
cuz the logic is slightly more intricate
than I had
turn turn action
float at
not move
turn
body okay wait no it is
turn just caps
you okay I have it
right faster you're moving the slower
okay so this is literally the same it's
just a clip function
degrees okay then we
clip nice very very
simple very simple stuff right
turn oh these are kind of gross though
to put these as separate functions
because you need to know the
clipping
well what we can do is we can just make
this uh we can just make this
return we can have this return degrees
right so we can
Okay so this actually has to get called
first right
you do
this
movement then you
turn and then we can
do it's just going to
be gun
this and then we can do the
float
yeah there we go
here good not need this anymore right
did I forget this
though no I didn't forget
this you move you
turn turn The Gun turn the
radar all redundant from
here what's
this this is part of movement we already
did
okay well I don't know what's happening
here
happening we probably need to go wire up
the controls
zero you move forward
I don't know 16 units or
something uh there's something wrong
with my my setup hold
on
get yeah there was something
there my auto completes
okay so the first two these are action
zero towards the
movement and then the second one is turn
in
degrees
QE now this is going to be a and d
right though actually I like the idea of
using q and for radar and stuff that
would be
cool uh
yeah what
happened oh this
is on a
here oh
um no
this shouldn't make a difference
right yeah
190 why is the position totally messed
up
okay okay so it spawns at some random
position on the map
dumb yeah it's really dumb okay
um how do I want to do
this oh yeah this is yeah I was just
totally stupid here 100% totally stupid
um
yeah what we'll do for now
is for
I'm not in the mood to even I can't even
think about basic physics right
now well this is
interesting we're actually
um well that's
uh
hi what are you building right now
well certainly not this uh this is
supposed to be a reinforcement learning
environment in which tanks fight each
other but it's produced some abstract
form of
artwork this is actually like incredibly
cool to
yeah this is hey Nathan uh this is
probably the most entertaining bug I've
seen in a very long
all right we have uh We've appreciated
this for long
enough how are M's going along that
coming along Nathan we've got some new
cool stuff I don't know if you've
seen I built a little little TCG for
Puffer that uh hopefully people are
going to add
to what do we call this puffer the
schooling you know L your
land kind of Magic the Gathering
e definitely need some more stuff added
to it but uh
yeah you can
there's a Max there's a speed limit that
I forgot to enforce right
okay this
works the turn rate is too
slow but it seems to
okay so this kind of does the thing now
the radar is no longer rendering which
is not great
uh this is still oh no this is now
rendering
right look at that so you actually you
can see the ra the uh the radar
yeah gun is way too
long this can be
though um I'm trying to think what we do
next here if we mess with firing or we
try to like get all of this stuff
actually working well
I'm kind of interested in how we would
do firing
stuff I don't think it's that hard let
me
well so we'll just
do
bullets bullet has an x a y Lo
V has a
it then the en is going to have to
have bullet star our
bullets so we definitely need we need
the fire action
this will be kind of a fun function
right void
robot Gun
heat greater than
zero
get we also need a
bullet index of some sort don't
incremented and
actually yeah there you go cuz it's
circular it wraps around
bullet damage
is we don't need to know
that we actually don't need to know the
velocity either at
all
terministic just need X Y heading and
fire
barrel and then we do bullet X
actually I think this can just
beet
xet
y
it
okay and then we uh have to do update
bullets
fine let me see how this
is all buet
move yeah so the bullets always move
first so what we actually have to do is
we do this Loop up top like
this and just repeat the
loop
bullet
Adder I times num
bullets yeah so this is what we want
bullet V equal
20.0
Fus 3
* bullet fire
power that's slow enough that you're
basically never going to miss
right it's going to move at most 20
pixels
and the robot's always bigger than 20
pixels you're always going to you can
technically like clip over the edge or
something but I think it's fine
check can you collide with your own
bullets you probably
DX what do we say distance is
here how big is this
32 so if you're within 32 or
whatever for
oh we also need to do a
live
or
live hi
welcome how's it going
here we know the bullet is live we know
we have live
Munitions we need to
do I actually want to do this the other
way this is a Contin this will be
cleaner
so damage
damage four time fire bullet Firepower
then
if fir power is greater than
I don't know where they get this formula
from but
Health uh the robot firing this
thing gets energy back
bullet that's it right and bullet live
is going to be
oh we just have to add yeah there we
go so now we
have basic bullet Collision checking
prototyped we have to add a fire
action we have to add a fire
action uh we'll see how we're going to
do this
what's this going to
be load Firepower is going to
be action
here
and if fir
power is greater than
zero we
fire that's literally it
space and
then what's this gun heat thing
reset so heading energy Health robot Gun
heat is set to three
let's see if uh let's see if we can get
this to work we got to draw the bullets
as well right
do what I
miss bunch of stuff looks like
[Music]
163 I
miss uh this is going to be something
stupid
right
close I closed this brace
here this is some dumb syntax
error wait I do
I probably should have syntax
highlighting
actually is that just built in do I need
a plug
up looks
fine what I also add didn't I also add
I'm just looking if there's anything
built
this
huh well that's uh not what we wanted
now is it
that
oh duh
agents yeah I just I totally messed this
up right this is you go through
indented cuz you have to
check each agent has a number of bullets
yeah this is fine
we zero out our action buffer
correctly now it will not just
infinitely fire
right way
better and also we have
to not infinitely update
be way
[Music]
better now we actually have like a basic
tank looking game right
so next
thing we need to understand is the uh
the health system and
whatnot oh we're almost at 600 members
here I just realized it's cool speaking
of which all the stuff that I'm uh
building here is all free and open
source you want to support the project
for
free drop it a star on GitHub helps us
out a
ton and you're free to come chat in the
Discord as well we do a lot of cool Dev
stuff a lot of these Ms are built by
contributors you actually don't even
really need AI experience or that much
of it to build the environments
themselves um puffer takes care of a lot
of that for
trying to find the um the docks here so
we can implement the health and we can
actually get multiple Bots into this
maybe we'll even script a
couple for opponents to play
it is it just your health is your energy
is that
okay so we have right
here uh Power
rules that's how we do our better
Collision checking in the future
draw actually we'll just draw text as
how it's done in the real thing
right draw
robot X this is got to be net
minus
okay you can see then we have our we got
our bot right it's got energy or
whatever my energy does not decrease
when I fire a
bullet you have
to I think it costs you energy to fire
bullets doesn't
it looks like you just
um it just detracts from your
we should now see energy
updating yeah there you see right PE PE
loses energy for firing bullets
good
uh can we get a second bot into here
that works
perfectly we don't have Collision
checking on the actual Bots themselves
yet but we do have you
here I wonder if we can grab the
assets what's the license this is uh
what's the license this is under
EPL it's not really commercial use
anyways
weing Eclipse
license too
complicated uh where are the
assets samples
net SF Robo
code UI
where
are
the uh
pngs where the pngs
ground little tiny
PNG
yeah I think we just download This and
like try to put together a Sprite sheet
right that'll be a reasonable thing to
do real quick
wait are they still releasing stuff
here oh cool this project is actually is
still active that's
nuts I didn't even realize
this is really such a cool project it's
just the code base is ridiculous
all right where did we say that we had
the
images
so robo
codei Source
main resource
images we make these into a nice Sprite
sheet
technically they're really not these
many of these they're not that many of
these don't have to do a Sprite
on billboards as Sprite
sheet no idea it doesn't matter the
rendering is just for visualization
anyways we're not training on
pixels we could train on pixels probably
tens of thousands maybe 100, steps per
second but we're going to be able to
train on state at well over a million
there we
go
turret there we go
so these are the key components
sheet I don't really like how this is
organized as the main the uh the one
thing here
yeah let me think
here do they use all these different
tiles or do they only use like
I'm not think do I just want to make the
Sprite sheet
bigger probably would be easiest right
zero oh it's because of this
there we
this
work there we
go
[Music]
we do this and then we do
texture
64 no they're not so we figure that
out um but then load texture robocode
PNG
Atlas your load
how do I do it here make
client
so this
is 64 time
Rand
x Rand per
64 now it's 64 times Rand per
5 like this
Source
X desk direct
perfect and then what is the size of the
robo code map I guess we can do that in
a
star
this is now
make
client let's figure out let's just
figure out the robo code map
size this is like what I remember
right uh can we not just see from right
here oh it's actually not a it's not a a
great fix size is it
so I think we just get to choose it's
roughly
[Music]
9 it's probably 10 it actually probably
is 720 by 1080 isn't
it
576 okay and now we need to do the
client
star client it's going to be make
client star client it's going to be make client this says
pause what the heck is wrong with
this texture Source position
tint texture Source oh
it's
dumb and then I
this rooc code
Atlas it's not rendering my texture
because name is
wrong and then you can't just do Rand
percent five it has to be um
I don't know we need like some hash here
that's uh consistent don't we
I should use primes but whatever does
this actually look good let's
see yeah this actually ends up looking
just
fine oh does it have a stripe pattern
yeah it does have a stripe
two I don't know probably this is good
enough
right still get a strip pattern because
I'm doing a
multiply for
this produces a freaking repeating
pattern doesn't
it no they just used it as a seed this
is utterly
I think wait should I just be
multiplying
them and she can't be multiplying them
either right
actually why wait why does this produce
a striped pattern like
this is such a stupid thing to get hung
up on this is such a dumb basic problem
I just don't know
H well I have no idea if this is any
good
why what happens if I do
this
gross yeah this is they don't get it
this is not the same thing
whatever we'll just ignore it for
now we'll literally we'll just ignore it
to
now yeah what did I have before that was
just
like or
whatever uh so we have our
robots they have
terrain they fire
stuff we want our tanks
this one does need to
be uh tilted as well
this is going to
be what's our Atlas look
like
texture texture Pro
need
okay to
or
rotation it's going to be
heading raw texture
row zero and this is actually
robot
heading and this
is
body
okay
and then this will hopefully we'll have
the the whole uh the whole tank drawn
ah so the origin actually has to be 32
32 I
believe and now look at that so they
actually do
turn the orientation is off by
90° because of their screwy coordinate
system
90 now they're
backwards the Plus
look at
that you get to drive your tank
around
radar and
whoops we can shoot the other tank
uh in
y ver y =
colors uh that didn't give us different
colors hold
on there we go
so we can now see this
here we can comment the
right it actually doesn't look half
bad
um
48 and
projectiles are they just sparce is that
all they
yeah there we go now that doesn't look
half bad
right obviously there's no Collision on
the actual Bots themselves
for how long have I been live two hours
hour 20
minutes yo did you find a port of Robo
code oh is this what welcome no I just I
wrote this um
yeah I wrote this I took their
assets um but yeah it's only 300 lines
so far and like it's not going to be
that long the original has literally 20
times more code than it needs
today I'm trying to think what I want to
do on this next
mechanic also did I miss news
here oh yeah
well we definitely want the
headings to
be
manageable uh I'm trying to think how we
will
rotate I think that we want
the Q and E to rotate the gun Maybe
okay
um what's this do
Q oh look at
that oh look at that that actually looks
very very nice already and I just have
the radar stuck to the gun for now so
like you know you turn it's got a turn
radius
right it's actually surprisingly decent
for uh not a lot of work so
far probably we want to make the
collisions a little bit better
yeah and I'm going to take a few minutes
to use a restroom uh make myself a shake
and reset and then when I come back
we're going to figure out a few more
things to improve on this for today um I
think I want to at least
get I want to at least have this looking
like somewhat close to the real thing um
not with all the features and stuff
maybe we'll do like a basic scripted
agent or something like that uh if I can
find one to just like copy Logic for
because I'm not thinking about physics
today um but yeah I'll be right back
this is going to be
fun I'm actually you know I really
shouldn't be implementing this thing now
I should be working on one of my bigger
M's but for like a little thing on the
side uh for when I'm like kind of just
too burnt to work on the hard stuff this
is going to be a pretty short and easy
project to get something cool out of
code does um does like this type of uh a
thing look familiar to you
it was like this really old Java project
for like teaching people how to code by
getting them to like script a uh script
an AI for these guys
probably collisions of some variety and
observations and
such there a bunch of stuff to
do not that much code
though probably the Border
uh border things as
well let's see
yeah
so this
here I think this is -32
right I I can tell by uh by shooting at
it I think so if I just go to here
whatever we'll just go up into the
corner
I can't tell if it's
wrong well actually let's see maybe I
can tell based on
this so I'm at 0 right
now that
actually is that a quarter of the
tank I don't think it's a quarter of the
tank I'm kind of confused as to how this
is uh working this way
way oh cuz origin is okay yeah
yeah I know how that works that's fine
then then basically all I need to do is
add a buffer
yeah this will be
okay so now we can't go off the map
16 okay so now we can't go off the map and look stupid right we can clip a
and look stupid right we can clip a
little bit but that's fine
I think the move
is Collision check
okay we get the target
bot distance greater than
32 uh
we
continue we get the damage formula from
the wiki
where is the
um the physics thing I
thought oh wait I think I just do like
let's just go look
there's an article
tiny let me see what this does I don't
know if this
is reasonable
oh gosh the YouTube videos
from before we knew how to record
videos show the
bot oh no there it
goes okay so this
done oh it's because every 6 it just
keeps to doing the damage I see I
understand it's because it's not based
on your
speed that's kind of a silly mechanic
but I understand it that
wait yeah so we are both at zero
immediately because we spawn on top of
each
need to make sure that they're not on
top of each
right probably we just have to spawn
them
equals if the
distance is
less
break do Collide it is
true if
collided then we add all this
stuff and we increment the
index so now they should
guarantee what we do here this
oops
okay so now we can
see uh we still can't
move but we are not on top of each other
anymore which is good
uh actually you can do this this is
because this is just a check by address
so this is totally
fine yeah there we go that was the
bug now you can
see uh we can r
like that
ha and yeah that's like a reasonable
enough Collision detection
right
boom some physics and stuff we'll have
to adjust
overall what else are we missing at this
point not missing that much are we okay
um like some little scripting thing here
right it's
245 I'm probably do a little bit of
stuff with
zero is going to be
16 just going to go forward until it
hits the wall or
whatever this is the rotation we don't
care about this uh we do care about the
gun rotation
though so we need to get
the position of the opponent
1.x and then we need to get
the the
angle to the
robot right yeah angle to
robot
to this
targets then
if
angle component
is
then
two m. actions
fire
or oh
opponent so we need heading we need uh
gun heading right
float
gun heading
I'm just trying to make a very basic
test spot here
Delta ah there's just
um I see
is I even doing this
um let me think this arctan
it's gun
heading is it off by 90 Dees or
something weird
interesting it's shooting at roughly the
right
because what's this thing spit out
okay for so for
whatever oh yeah I'm just being utterly
stupid because the angle is going to be
in radians right yeah
let's actually make sure I understand
the range of
this so let's do
this okay it's plus or
minus and then gun heading is going to
have to be in
degrees uh so the angle has to
be 180 * this
/
this this doesn't seem to be working now
does
it oh that
interesting so it
works it works like from certain angles
I think this will work now
um pew pew pew
right how do I get this thing to
freaking
turn there we
go you can
see yeah so whatever it does it'll still
fire perfect
so we have a little bot that can play
this now kind of cool
why is it not firing at me do it need
energy I guess yeah probably needs
energy
what else is there I can do at the
moment
well not actually that that easy but we
can do the easy version for
yep hey
bet I'm pretty tired today but uh I got
one cool little environment thing
done let see does this work oh yeah this
battles this is kind of Jank and needs a
little bit of
work Tank Wars got it
yeah it's kind of funny that this is
actually kind of looking a lot like
robocode used to look and instead of
having literally hundreds of files this
is like I don't know a few hours of
screwing around in
see this has progressed extremely
quickly not really I'm honestly I'm
coding at probably less than half
productivity today I'm actually
exhausted it's been like ludicrously hot
all week and I've had tons of meetings
like I honestly at this point I kind of
want to just like do a couple quick
things with this and then like Hop Off
play some League get some food and like
get a good night's sleep and start
coding on uh some like harder stuff
tomorrow it's very difficult to play
this with the tank controls I will
say cuz it has like tank yeah it has
tank
controls had you muted well can't help
with that
puffer cool
texture uh I need to actually fix it
it's like it's diagonally striped at the
moment I just I stole the robo code ones
these are all the the robo code assets
that I just
stole I'm we can improve a few things
here
right anybody got any cool ideas for
stuff that's easy to add I mean I
already have the scripted bot the really
basic scripted bot should not be too
hard to beat that
thing I don't think I have it in me to
do the observations
today
um I can just Commit This so you guys
can play with it though I could
definitely do that
playing some doist okay that I'm not
allowed to
do um
I I am not allowed to download an MMO
that is not that will kill puffer as a
company
um
yeah
hey yeah Nathan I I sweated that game
like very very hard for a long
time did I tell you the crazy stuff ju
St
no I'm not even tempted to be honest uh
to download any MMOs at this point cuz I
just know I know it's heroin like league
and random stuff I can keep under
control I never get addicted to like a
mobile or like a comp game like that for
a huge amount of
time ah
CR so I'll tell you this thing this was
[Music]
hilarious why why is the freaking PNG
not
so this is like some random weapon I
found in the game that it it hits
twice and it costs two action points to
use right let me get this off the
freaking screen crazy French art
um but like I figured this thing has it
does it hits twice and it only cost two
action points so I figured out that you
could pair that with a different
character that has a really big ba
damage buff flat damage buff and you can
basically just like one turn anything in
the old version of the
game Nathan will uh we'll see where that
was
going there anything in the Discord if
not I'm probably just going to hop
Twitch yeah I mean this is is pretty
well
set I think for like a day one on this
project is not that
bad
oops Yeah for day one on this project
not very bad we got a little scripted
bot to play against uh the controls are
very hard but the controls in the
original game are very hard because it
it's tank controls
essentially so you're like you're
steering
it's also just hard to tell which way is
forward on a tank because it's like
symmetrical
ha it's funny that I can actually still
beat I can still beat this opponent bot
thing just by running it out of energy
because it's not very good at targeting
there needs to be more time nope there
is Li limited ammo you're using your
energy for the bullets and also these
are small bullets um You can fire bigger
bullets and that those have uh a longer
cool down I'm matching the original game
so there's not really any design to be
thought of to be honest I'm just
matching the original
game as best as I
can but yeah you literally can just run
it out of
ammo by doing
this limited counterplay well because
the policies aren't very like this is a
dumb scripted
bot there's actually a [ __ ] ton of
counter
playay it seems hard to beat I am
beating the bot I've beaten the bot
every single one of these games I'm the
blue
ammo yeah but you're like it's all
energy based so like when you shoot it
it does damage as
well so like I shoot it and it takes
damage right
okay well I am tired for today I'm going
to I've committed this up you guys can
play with it can you make it better
easily um yes but not today you actually
have to do a a little bit of math what
about a maze
game is pathf finding suitably made with
what you can
show um so
you here's the thing with mazes
maze people have used mazes a ton in RL
and here's the problem with a maze right
in order to solve
this like you can't make any progress in
a maze without solving the entire
problem right like I have to literally
trace the entire path to solve like to
know if it's it's a good solution or not
so the reward is basically one for
solving the Maze and zero for solving
for not solving it
um this will actually eventually work um
you can do this with RL it's just not a
great problem because it's not going to
look particularly impressive because
like humans don't really need to solve
mazes like we already understand how
these things
work right we just kind of go like this
and yeah
there they're papers you can just solve
the thing with like RL will work for
mazes it's just that you need to
actually have it be
cool all right
I'm hopping off folks I'm tired um I
will yeah I'll pick back up on dev over
the weekend solo and hopefully I'll have
a version of that bigger project in a
good spot by then but uh my folks are
here over the weekend as well so I'll